das wandern ist nicht nur schweizer
volkssport nummer eins sondern gehen und
flanieren gelten auch als erprobte
methoden zum philosophieren
beim gehen komme man auf die besten
gedanken haben philosophen immer wieder
behauptet stimmt gar nicht sagt mein
heutiger gast florian werner s denkt
sich beim gehen überhaupt nicht
besonders gut dennoch hat der
schriftsteller eine wander buch
geschrieben mit dem titel der weg des
geringsten widerstandes
was er damit genau wo und wie gehen und
denken zusammenhängen unser thema heute
herzlich willkommen und herzlich
willkommen auch ihnen herr werner hallo
ich hierzu sind ja herr werner ein
kurioser titel der weg des geringsten
widerstandes ein wanderbuch wichtigen
das leben ein bisschen zum nissan
natürlich das leben ist ungeheuer mühsam
sinnlos und das führt zum tode hin
nein ich glaube warum es mir gingen bei
diesem wanderbuch war diesen imperativ
immer de neben den größten widerstand zu
suchen bei wanderungen immer den
höchsten gipfel die längste strecke die
europäische union an den außengrenzen
abzuwandern oder irgendwie europa von
sauerstoff ohne sauerstoff ohne
zigaretten dass man zu hinterfragen uns
gucken was passiert eigentlich wenn man
eben nicht höher schneller weiter gehen
möchte sondern einfach sich ziellos
treiben lässt
von zu hause weg sie sind ja ein großer
wandel haben sie nicht auch eine
faszination für so extrembergsteiger
ueli steck oder reinhold messner
natürlich bin ich fasziniert von denen
weil die die grenzen dessen was menschen
möglich zu sein scheint immer wieder
erweitern in gefilde die uns
normalsterblichen wanderern und
bergsteigern unerreichbar sind
und da glaube ich auch das problem dass
die die fußstapfen eines reinhold
messner oder so gewaltig riesig sind
dass man da ja hineinfällt wenn man
versucht die nahe zu treten
ich glaube es gibt aber auch ein
grundsätzliches problem nämlich dass die
eigentlich nicht als vorbild taugen also
bei aller faszination die ich habe für
solche großartigen bergsteiger und und
auch autoren
dieser zugrundeliegende imperativ der
uns glaube ich in der westlichen kultur
sehr vertraut dass wir nicht dass man
unter beständiger vertikal spannung
steht würde der philosoph peter
sloterdijk sagen also dass man immer
nach höheren sternen strebt und immer
nach oben gezerrt wird aber nie auch mal
in der ebene sich ausbreiten kann
das fand ich könnte mal hinterfragen und
gucken was passiert wenn man sich diesem
imperativ der vertikal spannung geben
nicht unterwirft und dann haben sie
sozusagen im sommer 2017 entschieden
jetzt mach ich mal gegenprogramm weg des
geringsten widerstandes und haben da
ihren rucksack gepackt in berlin
isomatte schlafsack und sind einfach los
gestopft genau ich habe mir so einen
zehn-punkte-plan aufgeschrieben vorher
oder zehn gebote habe ich sie ganz
großspurig genannt nachdem ich mich
orientiert habe bei einer meiner
wanderung und das erste gebot besagt
ebenso zu hause weglaufen und soll keine
karte dabei hatten keinen gps benutzen
und einfach an jeder ecke an der man
ankommt den weg des geringsten
widerstandes wählen also wenn es eben
rechts bergauf geht dann geht man
natürlich noch längst wenn der wind
gerade von osten weht dann lässt man
sich nach westen treiben
und wenn da eine wegs ein bisschen
grüner und bequeme erscheint dann ist
man auf jeden fall den etwas was mich
interessiert hat ist dass sie sich im
buch sozusagen immer auch über den
schreibprozess wieder lustig machen der
sie auch begleitet das heißt sie wussten
eigentlich von vornherein auch sie
wollen ein buch darüber schreiben
widerspricht sich das nicht einerseits
weg des geringsten widerstandes mal
keine vertikal spannung und gleichzeitig
wissen daraus muss jetzt aber ein tolles
buch werden
ja da legen sie natürlich ein bisschen
den finger in die wunde wobei sehr viele
freunde und gelehrte bekannte den ich
von dem projekt erzählt habe schon von
forderungen gesagt haben aber am aller
und widerständig ssten wäre sowieso erst
ganz zu hause zu bleiben natürlich klar
bequemer ist es auf dem sofa sitzen zu
bleiben und gar nicht zu wandern
aber es war mir schon wichtig dass es
eben ein weg ist dass es eben keine ort
des games widerstandes ist dass wir das
sofa sondern wirklich eine strecke die
ich mache und natürlich hatte ich als
ich jetzt mitgebracht hier dann so
diverse schreibt dabei in denen ich
immer wenn ich mittagspause gemacht habe
oder so erst mal notiert habe was mir
durch den kopf gegangen ist während der
wanderung aber sie kommen sich trotzdem
richtig gehen lassen wenn sie immer
wussten dass es war so eine mischung
einerseits ließ ich mich gehen und
treiben und wusste ihn wirklich
überhaupt nicht jetzt von zu hause in
berlin prenzlauer berg wird es mich eher
in richtung polen treiben oder er nach
norden oder nach süden wenn ich nach
italien handeln oder in der schweiz oder
irgendwo in westdeutschland
andererseits natürlich ich hatte glaube
ich eine sehr gespannte erwartung die
ganze zeit als ich habe aber das finde
ich auch durchaus angenehm ich hatte
alle sinne versucht zu öffnen weil ich
natürlich wusste klar ich möchte darüber
schreiben
und das führt ihr glaube ich schon zu
einer sehr sehr großen präsenz dass ich
versucht habe wahrzunehmen eben genau
woher wird eigentlich der wind wie ist
eigentlich die topographie von dem
berliner umland dass ich eigentlich sehr
gut kenne aber dass man so ganz genau
darauf achtet wo verlaufen habe ich die
bäche und ströme großen gesenkt wo sind
die uhr stromzähler der letzten eiszeit
oder so das feld an glaubt sehr sehr
intensiv auf wenn man nach diesem
prinzip wandert und dazu gehört eben
auch keine karte dabei zu haben weil man
sonst natürlich gucken würde wo geht der
weg lang gemäss karte sie werden aber
fast wortbrüchig werner ist ein bisschen
karten süchtig gervers nicht an sich
halten als am alleine auf dem tisch
liegt kartoffel ich das nennen ja genau
in einer herberge wo ich denn mal bei
regen unter gekommen bin erwarte er sich
an das sortiment an wanderkarten
stand er im frühstücksraum und ich muss
gestehen ich finde wanderkarten toll
also es macht ist ein großes vergnügen
sie zu lesen sich in diese göttliche
perspektiven zu begeben und von oben
drauf zu gucken wo man wandern könnte wo
man gewandert ist wo man vielleicht war
dann wird demnächst aber ich glaube
dieser göttlichen perspektive ist auch
schon ein problem benannte nämlich das
wird er zu einer gewissen spaltung des
selbst wenn man mit karte wandert also
so schön es ist aber man ist immer
doppelt einerseits befindet man sich in
der landschaft als kleines pünktchen
aber in dem moment wo neben rauskommt
und auf die karte guckt sieht man sich
eigentlich eben aus dieser göttlichen
früher hat man gesagt oh da sagt man
google ist aus dieser perspektive ganze
natürlich die reise gehen und sagen
vogelperspektive aber es ist eben dieser
blick von oben und ich glaube dass wir
zu seiner gestaltung in beobachter und
beobachteter subjekten objekt man ist
immer so ein bisschen doppelt und
vielleicht nicht ganz bei sich sondern
eben doch der planende von oben der den
weg versucht zu bestimmen
ich habe irgendwo wenn lustigen spruch
gelesen mit gps keine abenteuer erlebt
das hat der gedanke wahrscheinlich hätte
er weniger erlebt ich glaube schon dass
dieses also auch und es soll es gut er
hatte viele widerstände zu bewältigen
aber er ließ sich natürlich auch treiben
von den winden die ihm oft mich wohl
gesonnen waren und bestimmt entdeckt man
eben sehr sehr viel mehr am wegesrand
wenn man nicht weiß wo man hingeht das
war auch eine sache die mich
interessiert hat an diesem projekt
heutzutage eben im zeitalter von gps von
google earth von bewertungsportalen im
internet ich weiß gar nicht wie sie alle
heißen erscheint ja eigentlich jede
wanderung jede reise ungeheuer planbar
wir können schon vorher genau
herausfinden welche farbe die schirmchen
auf den cocktails in dem hotel dass wir
schon vor monaten gebucht haben haben
werden das heißt es die kontingenz ist
eigentlich vollkommen ausgeblendet und
mich hat eben interessiert was passiert
eigentlich wenn man eben diese
kontingents ist im moment dass
zufälligen des willkürlichen mal wieder
dem richtig breiten raum einräumt und
aber sagt ich habe keine ahnung wo ich
heute mittag essen und wo ich oder am
schlafen werde
und ich gucke einfach mal was passiert
einer der das ja auch extrem betrieben
hat ist der basler soziologe lucius
burckhardt der hat in den 1980 er jahren
die kuriose idee gehabt die spaziergangs
wissenschaft zu erfinden oder auch die
promenade logi klingt ein bisschen
lustig ich habe lustige bilder gefunden
aus jener zeit hören dialogs burkhardt
ganz kurz zu
das spazierengehen ist die natürlichste
art sich eine landschaft oder eine stadt
zu erschließen allerdings spazieren wir
heute nur noch selten durch die welt
hochgeschwindigkeitszüge rücken städte
und regionen näher zusammen
das flugzeug bringt uns in wenigen
stunden zu fernen kontinenten
wir sind mobil wie nie zuvor und das hat
folgen für unsere wahrnehmung wie sehen
die welt im schnelldurchlauf
entsprechend unscharf sind die bilder
und vorstellungen in unseren köpfen
die spaziergangs wissenschaft versucht
sich darin das betrachten
wiederzuentdecken betrachten heißt neue
blickwinkel erschließen sie weisen
ausprobieren ungewohntes wahrnehmen
störende elemente aufdecken fehler
machen und bei sich selbst bemerken
spaziergangs wissenschaft will ein
anderes verständnis von zeit und raum
gewinnen
spazierengehen de menschen sind schon
durch den gebrauch ihrer füße langsamer
und dass sie gehen weil sie dazu lust
haben und nicht um anzukommen
sind sie zeitlich unberechenbar fast ein
bisschen ihre theorie aus brokat und
seine promenade logi ist natürlich ein
wichtiges vorbild für dieses projekt das
ich hier beschritten habe wobei ich
glaube der große unterschied ist schon
das bei burckhardt immer der städtische
raum sehr im vordergrund stand als er
wollte glaube ich die lebensfeindliche
planung unserer welt eben in den 80ern
darauf hinweisen wie auch städte immer
unwirtlicher werden für den
spaziergänger für den fußgänger- und hat
das eben mit hilfe seines spaziergangs
wissenschaft getan
während ich doch gemerkt habe ich habe
ganz starken impuls ich bin natürlich
über die losgelaufen mit werde auch mal
durch hamburg gekommen
aber eigentlich mich
in stetten abzuwenden und das wandern
was ja noch mal anders als das passieren
eben in die landschaft hinaus zu
betreiben
es steht natürlich lucius burckhardt war
ja auch ein großer organismus kritiker
ihr habt diese ganze urbanisierung auch
die vielen autos die immer überall mehr
ihre wege eben gesucht haben kritisiert
gleichzeitig gibt es ja schon so etwas
in dieser ganzen spaziergangs
wissenschaft was ich interessant finde
wenn man ihr buch liest nämlich diese
möglichkeit wenn man einfach mal los
geht eben sich überraschen zu lassen von
landschaften die sozusagen hinter der
haustür lauern die man nie sehen würde
wenn man die trampelpfade die man aus
dem alltag kennt immer lang würde auf
jeden fall also das war auch eine
faszinierende erfahrung die ich gemacht
habe bei meiner wanderung ich bin ich
sehr sehr viel zu fuß oder weg sehr viel
mit dem fahrrad unterwegs in berlin das
heißt ich dachte immer ich kenne
eigentlich relativ viele ecken aber das
hat glaube ich nur ungefähr eine halbe
stunde gedauert bis ich auch in berlin
mitte wo ich seit jahrzehnten zu hause
wenn plötzlich winkel entdeckte war ich
noch nie war ich dachte das hier ist ein
ein kiez ein viertel
da war ich noch nicht da kenne ich
niemanden der hier wohnt ich kenne die
die klasse plastiken und statuen im
öffentlichen raum nicht und das fand ich
toll geben durch dieses sehr willkürlich
prinzip mit diesen zehn gebote nicht
mehr aufgestellt habe wenn mein auto zu
gelangen
die einen vollkommen fremd sind sie
werden 17 tage unterwegs sein und
schlussendlich in bremervörde genau und
nehmen nach dem zug zurück und das
dauert zwei stunden
genau das hatte man sich schon ein
bisschen wie es im fall war das ganze ja
die frage nach dem sinn darf man sich
glaube ich bei literatur und philosophie
nicht nicht immer sofort stellen
aber ich glaube gerade das was eben auch
in dem kleinen beitrag über herrn
burkhard anklang nämlich dass man seinen
gewohnt das verständnis von zeit und
raum wieder hinterfragt neu justiert das
war mir natürlich sehr wichtig und das
vereint sicherlich die immunologie und
meinen herangehen und man merkt dem
plötzlich jemand kommt wirklich
wahnsinnig langsam voran
klar man könnte das auch alles mit dem
auto in zwei stunden machen am zweiten
abend meine wanderung da war ich
wirklich schon sehr sehr viele stunden
gegangen ich hätte auch abends den bus
nehmen und eine halbe stunde später zu
hause übernachten können aber ich hab's
trotzdem vorgezogen mein zelt am wannsee
aufzuschlagen und dort den wildschweinen
zu lauschen
auch das eine neue erfahrung es gab
immer wieder leute die ich auch
begleitet haben abschnittsweise und
viele haben gefragt was machen sie denn
hier dann haben sie gesagt ich gehe den
weg des geringsten widerstandes
und dann haben wir gesagt aha der weg
ist das ziel und bei regen sich auf na
ja dass ich mich aufrege ist vielleicht
ein bisschen zu hart gesagt
möglicherweise habe ich diese formel
oder es ist ja schon fast eine floskel
der weg ist das ziel
ein oder zweimal zu oft gehört um sich
darüber zu freuen
ich habe mich aber auch gefragt ob das
nicht dem weg dann doch wieder eine
große bürde auf lastet wenn man sagt der
weg das ziel dann ist es ja plötzlich
wieder dann ist ja wieder eine vertikal
spannung da dann muss man eben den weg
mit grosser wichtigkeit belasten
gleichzeitig hatte ich auch das gefühl
dass meine wanderung durchaus ein ziel
hat ein ziel punkt an dem ich ankommen
werde
ich kannte ihn nur einfach nicht naja
das war letzten endes
überraschenderweise bremervörde von der
der große deutsche humorist und dichter
wilhelm busch hat einmal über sie
gedichtet angeblich ein schön ist auf
der ganzen erde am schönsten doch in
bremervörde
ich weiß nicht ob das heute noch stimmen
das ist nur über 100 jahre altes gewicht
aber das war nun auch ein ort von dem
ich mir nie im leben träumte dass ich
dich mal hinkommen würde ich hätte es
auch ich wusste gar nicht in seiner
existenz
und plötzlich war ich ihm dort und habe
diesen ort erkundet sie beginnen während
des gehens aber auch darüber
nachzudenken wie sich denn eigentlich
ziel und leben zueinander verhalten und
sagen ihr ganzes leben sei eigentlich an
herum ihren gewesen
geprägt vom ziellosigkeit da habe ich
mich gefragt kokettiert er jetzt ein
bisschen nicht machen sie sind ein
erfolgreicher schriftsteller sie machen
radiosendungen sie sind vater von zwei
kindern
gleichzeitig glaube ich auch noch musik
oder also sowieso los scheint
wer sagen wir mal so ich glaube diese
tendenz dass man eine wanderung als
vorbildhaft und das gleichnis oder
lebensweg betrachtet ist schon sehr alt
und spätestens in der
im zeitalter der romantik wird dass so
ein stehender top aus das eigentlich
wanderung bedeutet aus dort sofort
eigentlich dass man einen lebensweg
beschreiten ist vorbildhaft ist eine
reise das hat man dann irgendwie in den
liedern von franz schubert oder sind
natürlich immer über die winterreise ist
eine besonders kalte und düstere
lebensweise da wird es also vertieft
dieser topos und ich habe mich natürlich
gefragt warum mache gerade ich mich es
auf diesem weg des geldes widerstandes
ohne plan und passt vielleicht dieses
romantische verständnis auch auf mein
leben und dachte möglicherweise ist kein
zufall klar es war nicht so dass ich
schon mit 18 wusste ich möchte später
gerne hautarzt werden oder jurist was
auch immer sondern ich habe natürlich
immer viel geschrieben ich habe viel
musik gemacht
ich bin ja auch nicht unzufrieden in
meinem leben aber es gab eben nicht
diese große karte diesen masterplan oder
das gps wo ich eingegeben habe okay das
ist mein ziel und auf diesem weg komme
ich am schnellsten dahin sondern ich
habe durchaus auch immer wieder umwege
gegangen auf dem lebensweg die ist auch
nicht unbedingt bereue was ich so
wahnsinnig interessant fahren ist dass
ich irgendwann für mich gedacht habe der
weg des geringsten widerstandes wäre für
mich ein weg der ein ziel hat weil
ziellosigkeit unglaublich widerständig
ist das ist doch schwer auszuhalten ist
das ist tatsächlich eine erfahrung die
ich auch gemacht habe unterwegs das in
dem moment wo man eben keine final
spannung hat jetzt nicht irgendwie den
berggipfel den herrlichen sie den
gasthof den zeltplatz den man anstrebt
das zoom ist nach einer weile das gehen
auch beschwerlich werden kann klar es
gibt nicht die diesen impuls faktor der
irgendwo hin zieht so dass dann doch der
weg ein wenig widerständiger wurde als
ich dachte und ich natürlich gemerkt
habe klar ziele helfen schon auch aber
zunächst mal diese erfahrung vollkommen
frei zu sein von verpflichtungen von
zielen
einfach nur drauf los gelaufen fand ich
großartig also wirklich sich dieser
vollkommen kontingents zu bewahren es
gibt eine szene die ich unglaublich
lustig finde da sitzen sie dann in
hamburg am strand pauli trinken ein
wässriges wir sind schon eigentlich
vollkommen fertig und dann fällt ihr
blick auf einen balken da draufsteht ist
soll ich mich gehen lassen
und das ist ja so eine lustige metapher
sich gehen lassen
eigentlich haben sich ja gehen lassen
ich habe mich ergehen lassen genau ich
vermute der eigentliche sinn dieser
inschrift eben in dieser strandbar dass
wir so ein politisches langhaus war
natürlich soll ich noch drei us
regierung ihre bestellen um mich in der
form gehen lassen aber als leidenschaft
her konnte ich dort hinzudenken okay
vielleicht ist auch gemeint ich
überlasse jemand anderem das gehen und
lasse mich irgendwie mit mitgehen und
das wäre natürlich wirklich der weg des
geringsten widerstandes gewesen aber ich
habe nicht bestritten
wenn man doch eine message auch sich
rausnehmen würde und er ist vielleicht
tatsächlich auch eine art protestmarsch
gegen ebendiese vertikal spannung gegen
dieses dauernde ein ziel haben ist etwas
verfolgen müssen etwas erreichen müssen
sich eben nicht treiben zu lassen und
sie denken auch darüber nach dass das
gehen und die politik oft miteinander
hand in hand gegangen sind viele große
sozialreformer waren auch protest
marschieren der denken hier angaben
dienten gern martin luther king
beispielsweise das für sie auch so ein
geschmack noch ja das ist natürlich
faszinierend was sie gerade erwähnt dass
beginnt eigentlich erst im zwanzigsten
jahrhundert dass menschen um ihre
politischen ziele durchzusetzen 1930
daneben mit seinem großen salz marshall
so gegen die salzstreuer der britischen
besatzer dann 63 martin luther king ist
eine wortmarke washington
das wird plötzlich zu so einer fast mode
oder einer großen bewegung das
politische protest ländern
ich glaube der große unterschied ist
dass politische protest wandern es
braucht immer einen großen menschenmenge
ich glaube der gerechtigkeits marsch im
vergangenen jahr in der türkei
das waren zwei millionen menschen zu
heiligen zeiten und die sind dann von
ankara nach istanbul gelaufen
martin luther king ist natürlich nach
washington gelaufen
gandhi ist ans meer gelaufen hat dort
salz gesammelt das heißt es einerseits
braucht man eine große gruppe aber man
braucht auch dann doch ein sehr klares
ziel einen mythischen ort und das ist
eben oft damit wird das meer oder die
hauptstadt oder die größte stadt des
landes wie bei ist das heißt man hat ja
auf jeden fall so an schon eine final
spannung wo sich dann alles kulminiert
und hoffentlich die ziele erreicht
werden
das heißt sie hätten schon eine gruppe
gebraucht die den weg des geringsten
widerstands mit ihnen gegen wen
ja das hat es andererseits auch sehr
sehr schwer gemacht werden sich
natürlich immer hinter einigen müssen
was jetzt gerade der der geringste
widerstand ist und ich glaube einer
einer meiner regeln ist es
wahrscheinlich § 6 besagt auch denkt
nicht so lange nach das war mir also
wichtig dass man das hier ist nicht an
einer kreuzung stehe und erstmals um
ihre okay ist das hier vielleicht besser
oder hier besser wer hier
und wenn ich das dann noch aus
diskutieren müsste mit einer
demokratischen gemeinschaft das hätte
vielleicht doch das serbische
entschleunigt wieder meine wanderung
haben sie sich diese regeln eigentlich
vor dem waren dann gegeben oder während
es waren das immer wieder angepasst
ich habe sie mir natürlich vor dem
wandern gegeben
ich hab dann unterwegs immer wieder so
verfassungszusatz erlassen
ich nenne dem buch nennt man in amerika
die verfassungsgesetze zur
amerikanischen verfassung weil ich
merkte dass eben doch diese zehn regeln
vielleicht nicht hundertprozentig
ausreichend um diesen weg zu beschreiten
also zum beispiel kam ich wenn ich meine
regeln gefolgt bin einmal immer wieder
am selben punkt raus
nach einer stunde ich bin also immer im
kreis gelaufen und offensichtlich waren
die bedingungen so dass sie dazu führten
und dann habe ich eben meine nummer eins
oder zwei erlassen das besagt man muss
das nicht mehrere male machen man darf
dann ausbrechen in einer beliebigen
richtung auch längst an kurzem
widerstand hat auch wenn es großen
widerstand hat aber sonst wäre die
wanderung sehr schnell zu ende oder eben
im kreis verlaufen in sogenannte ist ihr
training oder im fluss
der beschluss ist ein gutes stichwort
das sind ja eigentlich bei der
philosophie oder beim denken beim gehen
und beim denken und das ist ja wirklich
interessant dass das das gehen und das
denken in der philosophiegeschichte
immer ganz eng verwoben waren oder es
immer wieder ganz viele videos gegeben
hat die gesagt haben das gehört ganz eng
zusammen also natürlich angefangen bei
thales der denken an den himmel stand in
den brunnen gefallen ist dann denkt man
an aristoteles mit seinem peri peri
pathos also der wandelhalle wo er seine
philosophie entwickelt hat aber auch
kommt war ein spaziergänger russo war
ein spaziergänger
es gibt eine ganze menge niki regale
sind spaziert sie sagen aber vielen dank
diese behauptung dass man besonders gut
vieles wären könnte beim gehen das ist
ein ausgelatschte warum das ist
vielleicht ein bisschen hart formuliert
genießen kommen ja ziemlich sie haben
natürlich recht interessanterweise wenn
man noch weiter zurückgeht als totales
und wirklich in die evolutionsgeschichte
zurückblickt dann fangen gehen oder
überhaupt fortbewegung und denken
wirklich zeitgleich an sozusagen die
allerersten tierchen die sich noch nicht
bewegt haben die hatten auch noch kein
gehirn also wenn wir uns einen pilz
vorstellen oder einfach mal einen
seestern oder so der immer nur auf
seinem stein sitzt der braucht kein
gehirn erst in dem moment wo tiere
überhaupt ihren ort verlassen haben um
woanders hinzugehen haben sie dann auch
ein etwas wichtiges neuronales netzwerk
entwickelt und dann könnte man natürlich
sagen je mehr man denkt desto mehr muss
man auch gehen
das also ist verknüpft offensichtlich
dass die bewegung im geiste und die
bewegung im raum
insofern ist der topos von dem gehen und
denken und für das 4 natürlich absolut
richtig ich habe aber auch beim gehen
beim wandern die erfahrung gemacht dass
ist auch zu einer vollkommenen
entleerung des geistes führen kann oder
es hat sicherlich auch mit dem rhythmus
mit der ständigen repetition zu tun also
man macht dann irgendwie ich weiß ich
habe mal durchgerechnet vielleicht zu
30.000 und 40.000 schritte am tag wenn
man werden die weit läuft wenn man tut
also das immer gleiche und das führt
natürlich dazu dass man irgendwann auch
gar nichts mehr tut und
auch gar nichts mehr denkt wirklich
vollkommen in diesem monat ohne und im
schlimmsten fall vielleicht auch ein
wenig stumpfen rhythmus des gehens
befangen ist die jetzige sondernummer
des philosophie magazin sich zum thema
waren dann und da drinnen gibt es ein
interview mit dem französischen
philosophen frederico und er betont
genau das sehr sagt naja sondern das ist
repetition repetition das finde ich
interessant dient eigentlich dem
vergessen und habe mir dann überlegt
mein tier vielleicht so etwas wie
vergessen ist eine notwendige bedingung
um ins philosophieren zu kommen weil die
erst einmal auch das was ihr uns da
schon an gelesen haben oder schon immer
gedacht haben loslassen müssen was auf
jeden fall interessantes in diesem text
von herrn grohe mehr sagt dass 14
vergessen aber zunächst mal führt der
repetition oder wiederholung eigentlich
zu einer intensivierung das heißt ich
glaube es ist eher so eine kurve wenn
man eine sache man kennt das ja von wenn
man ein gedicht auswendig lernt oder
vokabeln lernt man muss erstmal
repetieren um sich etwas merken erst
wenn man es drei vier fünf sechs sieben
mal getan hat dann intensivierte sich
für das dichter im gehirn oder auch im
körper eine bewegung und dann aber
irgendwann geht diese kurve glaube ich
auch wieder langsam abwärts dann wird
sie ebenso selbstverständlich diese
bewegung dass man sie gar nicht mehr
wahrnimmt und ich glaube darauf hebt er
ab und möglicherweise für das auch dann
doch zu einer befreiung von natürlich
den mustern in dem man songs bewegt von
sachen die man für selbstverständlich
erachtete die dazu führen dass man
wieder neue philosophieren kann oder neu
auf die dinge blickt und ich hoffe
natürlich dass mir das in dem buch auch
teilweise gelungen ist denn natürlich
habe ich nicht ständig nicht gedacht
sondern durchaus kam dann auch wieder
ins philosophieren es gab eben immer
wieder aber diese ich weiß nicht ob
durst oder erholungs strecken wo ich
auch völlig so eine sympathische lehrer
hatte ihn während des gehens das ist ja
auch interessant dass sie das jetzt
aufbringen weil man denkt na ja was hat
seine philosophie zu tun aber natürlich
östliche philosophie also dieses
meditative gehen hat ja immer eine ganz
große rolle gespielt eigentlich
situations praxis das ist nicht einfach
nur sitzen es ist eben auch dieses gehen
genau und auch eben diese repetitiven
körperlichen verrichtungen die nachher
eben zum möglicherweise zur erleuchtung
führen können
interessanterweise habe ich eben auch
während meiner wanderung eines abends
eine große chinesische reisegruppe nicht
wandergruppe aber ihr
wirtschaftsdelegation getroffen und kam
mit denen eben ins gespräch und erzählte
ihnen von meinem projekt und die
verständnis sofort gesagt dass das ist
genau das prinzip dass das senden das
nichtbefolgen und ab sofort also ganz
viele philosophische und literarische
lektüre hinweise geben für meinen
weiteren lebensweg
aber so aussagen wie eben ganz ganz
viele viele suchen sie gemacht haben wie
zwei spielt ihr gatte gesagt hat ich
habe mir meine besten gedanken
angelaufen so was würden sie nicht
unterschreiben dass ich bin jetzt nicht
sagen wenn sie an einem text brüten wenn
ich nicht mehr weiter kommen dann gehe
ich eben mal kurz im skeet süden dann
weiß ich es weitergeht
doch natürlich also das wäre ja ja das
brüten oder auch dass das grübeln das
grübeln ist ja ethnologisch verwandt mit
dem graben
das heißt man ist auf einer stelle und
man geht so lange im kreis mit dem
gedanken dass man sich selber in seine
gedanken hinein verklebt und ich glaube
tatsächlich sie haben absolut recht der
einzige weg heraus führt darüber dass
man aufsteht und den schreibtisch
verlässt und einmal um den block läuft
wird eine runde joggen geht radfahren
hilft auch bei mir immer wieder und
führt dann dazu dass dann irgendwann an
der nächsten ecke anhalten muss man ganz
schnell den block raussuchen und
aufschreiben
weil dann nämlich sich irgendein knoten
im hirn vielleicht eben aufgrund unserer
evolutionsgeschichte sich doch löst und
das denken wieder neue fließen kann
und wenn man dieses verhältnis ganz
genau auseinander nimmt dann fällt einem
natürlich sofort dieser texte hein
thomas bernhard gehen
eine unglaubliche skurrile erzählung
wahnsinnig komisch und da gibt es diese
wunderbare passage wo thomas bernhard
sagt wenn man einer person zu guckt wie
sie geht weiß man wie sie denkt wenn man
jemanden beim denken sozusagen sieht
oder guckt wie er denkt dann weiß man
auch mehr geht und ein bisschen denkt
man doch hat das tatsächlich etwas auf
ihren mann heute beobachten auf jeden
fall
was was thomas bernhard hier beschreibt
hingegen ich hatte diese erfahrung immer
wieder beim fußballspielen lustigerweise
ich spiele gerne mit anderen autoren
schriftsteller im fußball und da hat
immer wieder diesen moment klar fußball
hat natürlich auch was von gehen laufen
stehen bleiben rennen mensch der eine
kollege der immer so ballverliebt immer
nur ohne seine mitspieler zu sehen vor
sich hin dribbelt der schreibt
eigentlich auch immer nur um sich selbst
ja schreibt genauso wie er fußball
spielt also insofern hat herr bernhard
sicherlich vollkommen recht natürlich
die art und weise wie wir uns bewegen
sagt sehr viel aus über unseren zugang
auch zu unserem umgang mit mit text dann
natürlich sofort das fußballspiel ein
von monty python der philosophen wo die
philosophen unterschiedlich spielen je
nach denkweise dass sie haben ja wobei
sie interessanter weil sie zunächst mal
eben auch erst gehen ich weiß nicht wenn
sie sich erinnern haben anfang gibt es
einen angriff das spiel deutschland
gegen griechenland glaube ich
philosophen und dann passiert aber
erstmal gar nichts also keiner kümmert
sich um den ball sondern alle fangen an
eben wie bei asstel es in dem perry
pathos erst mal in so zweier grüppchen
einher zu schreiten und zu
philosophieren
bis dann irgendwann jemand ruft heureka
ich hab's und dann schnappt sich den
ball und das tor aber zunächst mal
mitgegangen ich bin fußball
ich fürchte das müssen andere beurteilen
ich selber noch zu betrachten beim
fußballspielen das ist glaube ich sehr
sehr schwer
nur dann hätten gegen gewusst was sie so
denken etwas was sie auch ein stück weit
zurück weisen in diesem buch ist dass
man sich selber näher kommt oder dass
man sich selber findet das ist ja eine
idee auch des pilgerns die einen plan um
zu gott zu gelangen und gott nahe zu
sein die anderen vielleicht kann man
sagen die weltlichen pilger die pilgern
um sich zu finden
sie sagen vergesst das mal findet
einfach nicht ja ich glaube das problem
ist jetzt ganz hart formuliert dass es
beides nicht existiert gott nicht und
das selbst auch nicht als ach da gibt es
jährlich viele menschen die daran
glauben dass es ihn gibt aber
das ist mir nicht geschenkt dieser
glaube aber auch bei dem bei dem ich das
kommt mir auch so vor wie so ein
klischee dass man sagt ich wandere um
mich selber zu finden vielleicht stoße
ich irgendwie unterwegs auf mich aber
wiederum mein gefühl war eigentlich es
geht beim wandern darum sich selber ja
zu verlieren
natürlich gibt es so etwas wie eine
identität was sich konstruiert über
soziale rollen die man ein leben als
familienvater als berufstätiger als
autor als mehr oder weniger öffentliche
person aber beim wandern geht es ja
gerade darum dass alles erstmal
abzustreifen und ein ja wirklich
unbeschriebenes blatt oder ein rollender
stein wenn man diese metapher möchte zu
sein und man könnte eben alle seien in
dem moment und das fand ich eben auch
ist eine große verheißung des wanderns
man trifft unterwegs menschen
aber was man sonst in seinem leben
möglicherweise an identitäten hat das
spielt in dem moment gar keine rolle man
es im moment einfach nur einwanderer wie
etliche andere auch ist sie war es mir
fällt da etwas ein nämlich es gibt den
großen einsiedler bruder klaus in der
schweiz das ist wirklich so eine ganz
zentrale figur auch in der schweiz der
war es kein großer wanderer glaube ich
aber einen hat er sich zurückgezogen hat
oder kein wenn ich ein einsiedler und da
gibt es das bruder klaus lied das habe
ich als kind gelernt und da gibt es die
stelle da sagte ja nehm ich mir gott
nimm mich mir und gibt mich ganz zu
eigen
also eigentlich ist das ja schon auch
eine idee der gläubigen man muss sich
selbst verlieren um zu gott zu sondern
in gott versenkt zu werden
also insofern würde ich das nicht einmal
widersprechen
wahrscheinlich also wenn man diesen
glauben hat dann glaube ich ist die
versenkung am ende der wanderung
natürlich ganz wichtig und da daran
besteht natürlich auch die pilgerfahrt
ob sie es nach jerusalem führt oder nach
rom oder eben nach santiago de
compostela ist ja schon auch der glaube
man kommt dort an und kommt als
geläuterter irgendwie anderer mensch an
und springt dann
möglicherweise in santiago uns ins meer
und wird im die reingewaschen von seinen
von seinen sünden und kommt als
verwandelt der mensch zurück
das heißt der glaube dass er sich sehr
stark und es schon seit vielen vielen
hundert jahren
sie haben aber immer wieder sie wollen
auf gar keinen fall ist eine pilgerreise
machen das ist nicht das was sie gesucht
haben und lernten doch dauernd
eigentlich auf dem pilgerweg
merkwürdigerweise obwohl ich mich ja
dann weit von santiago de compostela und
bewegt habe in norddeutschland also in
der nähe von hamburg bin ich dann
plötzlich eben auf dem pilgerweg nach
santiago gestoßen wo mir gar nicht
bewusst war vorher ich habe natürlich
dann später auf einer karte nachgelesen
wenn das also die sogenannte via baltica
also die ihm von der ostsee nach süden
führt und nachher die anderen pilgerwege
trifft und nachher münden alle in den
pyrenäen zusammen und führen nach den
tango dass diese via baltica also durch
hamburg läuft und dann bin ich
tatsächlich tage lang immer wieder ohne
es zu wollen
parallel zu diesem pilgerweg gelaufen
bis sich jemand crossen habe okay dann
bin ich eben pilger offensichtlich ist
es doch irgendwie von wem auch immer
gewollt mitbestimmt und lustigerweise in
dem moment wo ich das beschlossen hatte
habe ich den blick verloren also quasi
einen halben tag später waren plötzlich
diese schilder demir tagen begleitet
haben also dass eine jakobsmuschel als
symbol die ich immer wieder gesehen habe
waren einfach wie vom erdboden
verschluckt und so war ich also doch
eine verlorene seele
sie bekommen aber auch ein kinder
ständig in ihre bücher daran ja ich war
dann tatsächlich das war im flecken
harsefeld also in der nähe von hamburg
und da bin ich dann in die kirche
gegangen tatsächlich war dort eine
freund dame und die fragte mich dann
eben wo ich meine pilger büchlein hätte
weil sie mich für ein pilger hielt und
daraufhin habe ich immerhin hier meine
schreibt klare hingehalten und
freundlicherweise hier diesen ja wander
münch mir da rein gestempelt und eben
das offizielle wappen von von harsefeld
sie haben diesen stempel es dort drin
und immer wieder kommen sie eben
eigentlich auf diesem weg sie verlieren
ihnen auch wieder aber sie betreten auch
kapellen
es gibt momente wo sie sehr sentimental
werden angesichts dessen was ihnen in
der kapelle dazu steht ja in der tat ist
sie merken es vielleicht auch ich habe
natürlich auch eine jahre christliche
vergangenheit wenn man so will bin
dadurch sehr geprägt ich bin glaube ich
vor allem ästhetisch sozusagen von der
auch von der sprache allein der der
luther übersetzung der bibel extrem
geprägte merke doch das wie ich das
immer sehr ergreift und elisa ein kirche
was denn vor allem die passage der bibel
die geräte aufgeschlagen auf dem altar
lag die ich eben da und es war diese
wunderbare sprache von luther aber es
war auch aus dem buch samuel und so
heißt nur auch mein sohn also er ist
eben sich benannt nach dieser biblischen
figuren und da merkte ich ihn plötzlich
wie es mich überkam und ich doch große
sehnsucht nach meinen kindern meiner
familie überrollte und ich erinnerte
mich an paragraph 9 glaube ich meine
regeln des geringsten widerstandes wenn
sich die sehnsucht nach dann liegen über
übermannt dann geh nach hause
und tatsächlich dann zwei tage später
glaub ich hab ich geschossen okay also
wenn die wenn die zeichen so dicht gesät
sind
und schon die auch schon die bibel zu
mir spricht durch diese stelle dann muss
ich vielleicht doch jetzt zurück zu
meinem leben da ist irgendwie doch was
durchgedrückt in ihnen ja
sie begegnen auf ihrer wanderung immer
wieder auch tieren unterschiedlichen
tieren zwei tiere denen sie begegnen
haben sie auch bücher gewidmet nämlich
der crew sie haben ein großes buch
geschrieben über die crew und der
schnecke auf der schnecke haben sie ein
buch gewidmet ganz kurz vielleicht bei
der crew da schreiben sie in ihrem
wanderbuch immer wenn sie gesehen
müssten sie morgen kann ich das wirklich
ernst nehmen
das geheimnis glaube ich dass man sehr
tief in der brust und ansätzen zu einem
und dass damit die stimme so nach oben
um schlagen lässt ich weiß nicht wie das
passieren bekommen also sein also das
war nicht gut aber es geht eben so ganz
aus dem körper der bei mir natürlich
wirklich kleines vergleich zu seiner
trächtigen kuh und geht dann eben ganz
nach oben eher kühl habe mich schon
immer begeistert aber eben auch
schnecken also zum einen deswegen ist
bei das sehr sehr schöne tiere beide
hörner und sie werden glaube ich beide
zu unrecht verlacht also die kuh gilt ja
gerne als etwas schlicht etwas dämlich
vielleicht wenn sie so komisch auf der
weide steht und dort seine wieder kreuz
die schnecke wird wegen ihrer
langsamkeit verlacht aber ich glaube
beides sie hat zu unrecht
mir geht es immer so war dann wenn ich
sehe dass ich sofort mir immer wenn ich
immer frage was die wohl denken weil die
anja so anstalten auf jeden fall das war
für mich der impuls überhaupt dieses
buch über die kuh zu schreiben das ist
auch schon fast zehn jahre hier glaube
ich aber dass ich eben regelmäßig in
einem kuhstall war und ich sah ihm diese
tiere die natürlich wenn man den stall
betritt oder auch zu einer weile kommt
alle ankommen einen angucken mit diesen
großen klugen augen und man ist eben
diese riesigen köpfen
ich dachte eben auch mal da muss doch
irgendetwas vorgehende dresen stirn aber
sie können sich eben nicht richtig
äußern sondern es ist eingefangen eben
in dieser sprache der könig versucht
haben nach zu machen
dieses da muss doch etwas vorgehen ist
ja auch so ein bisschen ein
vermenschlichung des tiers und dazu
haben sie einen essay geschrieben in der
zeit noch gar nicht so lange her wo sie
sich eigentlich gegen diese
vermenschlichung des tiers ein bisschen
auch wehren was ist das problem an der
vermenschlichung des tiers oder was ist
überhaupt vermenschlichung was meinen
sie damit genau
naja es gibt in der philosophischen
tradition eigentlich schon seit auch
sehr teures total ist eigentlich immer
dieses bemühen mensch und tier
voneinander zu trennen und zu sagen das
konstruktive für den menschen ist
eigentlich dass er nicht so ist wie das
tier sind
dass der sprache hat das sehr
politisches system bildet usw
und dann eigentlich seit montana schon
also sind wir frühen neuzeit gerät es
immer mehr ins wanken und ich glaube in
den letzten jahrzehnten ist es doch sehr
stark dass eben diese sogenannte
anthropologische differenz zwischen
mensch und tier immer wieder untergraben
wird von beiden richtungen einerseits
neigen wir dazu tiere zu vermenschlichen
andererseits neigen wir glaube ich auch
dazu menschen zu terrorisieren könnte
man sagen also sie zum zum zum teil auf
griechische also zum tier zu machen aber
ich kann das noch ein beispiel geben
also gut die die vermenschlichung der
tiere natürlich im moment wo frauchen
für den pudel irgendwie eine decke
strikt oder im pullover und in der
rhein- packt dann macht man die
nachricht zusammen kleinen
minderwertigen menschen oder wenn man
nimmt zu sagt auch die pinguine sind
also niedlich der mir einen frack an
oder so und dann erscheinen sie aber
finde ich immer eher so als eigentlich
minderwertige menschen sehen aus wie
menschen
aber es sind eben doch nicht so fern und
begabt wie wir umgekehrt wenn menschen
zum beispiel erklären möchten warum sie
nicht vegetarier sind dann berufen sie
sich gerne eigentlich auf ihre tiere
heftigkeit und sagen ja gucken sie mal
wieder menschen wir haben doch reißzähne
wir haben einen sehr sehr langen
dünndarm das sind alles zeichen dafür
dass wir eigentlich als fleischfresser
konzipiert sind und deswegen
irgendwelche ethische dilemmata den
fleischkonsum betreffen die schere mich
nicht ich bin ja auch nur ein
trockenrasen primate biologisch gesehen
und so habe ich das gefühl dass
eigentlich dieses anrennen gegen die
anthropologische differenz zwischen
mensch und tier führt nicht dazu dass
wir tiere als unseres gleichen wirklich
ernst nehmen oder gar dass wir sie
besser behandeln oder besser halten
sondern eigentlich dazu dass sie uns
fast fast fremder werden und wir uns
moralisch verhalten und ich habe mich
immer gefragt ob es nicht viel
sinnvoller wäre wieder das staats machen
zu sagen natürlich klar
evolutionsgeschichtlich sind wir
trockenrasen primaten aber wir haben
eben bestimmte begabungen die tiere
nicht haben und diese begabungen die
bringen auch verantwortung mit sich eben
wir können über alternativen nach
wir könnten überlegen muss sich jetzt
wirklich dieses große steak auf den
grills meisten oder kann ich eben auch
an ein salat essen oder so und dass wir
eben es uns vielleicht so leicht machen
wenn wir sagen okay die tiere wir sind
doch eigentlich nur eins deswegen müssen
sie auf und quälen sie möglicherweise
und eine andere form dieser betonung der
radikalen differenz bestimmte auch darin
dass man in dieser differenz vielleicht
das andere bewundert oder also dass man
sieht na ja keine ahnung kann jetzt
vielleicht nicht besonders gut denken
aber naja ich kann vielleicht was das
ganze wieder von zum beispiel ist das
was ich glaube schon also das ist ein
gedanke der g auf der geht auch
friedrich nietzsche zurück
denn also sprach zarathustra einen
eremiten auftauchen lässt der im gebirge
sich befindet und umringt ist von von
lauter kühlen und zarathustra kommt ihm
zu ihm und stört ihn bei seiner
meditation mit den kühen und fragt ihn
eben also zuwachsraten ihre mieten was
machst du hier und er sagt ja ich will
den kühlen ihr glücksgeheimnis ab
lauschen und das besteht eben darin dass
sie wiederkommen können
und dann sagt eben und und wenn der
mensch auch alle seligkeit der welt
gewinne und erlernte das wiederkäuen
nicht dann würde er doch seine große
traurigkeit nicht los und ich glaube das
hat doch eine große weisheit weil kühe
wirken doch sehr sehr zufrieden
eigentlich wenn man sie auf so einer
schönen alpe oder so stehen sieht und
tatsächlich sie sind ganz bei sich sie
würden aus ihrem pansen wieder das hoch
was sie zu sich genommen haben
sie durften nicht ständig nach etwas
neues und sagen alles was ich brauche
habe ich hier in mir bei mir und das
denke ich aber noch mal und noch mal
durch meditative sind es braucht eben
nicht immer etwas neues und es kann auch
durchaus dass aus den pansen sagen
so habe ich mir das ehrlich gesagt noch
nicht überlegt das zu verinnerlichen
ich musste aus diesen texten in denen
los ist
über die vermenschlichung des tiers an
einem gast denken den wir einmal hier
haben nämlich charles foster ein
rechtswissenschaftler und bioethiker aus
oxford der gelebt hat wie verschiedene
tiere wie in daxing mauersegler fuchs
und so weiter und die polizei bei ihm
besteht eigentlich darin dass er gesagt
hat wenn wir lernen wie in tier zu leben
dann werden wir zu besseren menschen
hören ja auch ganz kurz zu was in
anderen köpfen steckt bleibt ein ewiges
geheimnis und das lässt uns mit einem
unbehaglichen gefühl zurück ich denke es
lohnt sich deshalb umso mehr
herauszufinden was im kopf einer amsel
vor sich geht was für eine welt sie
bewohnt das hilft uns bessere freunde
bessere liebhaber bessere väter zu
werden
ich denke ich habe einen winzig kleinen
fortschritt gemacht und er weiß wer also
sozusagen leben den tieren besserer
liebhaber zu werden wenn man sich ihren
orientiert im gespräch mit ja ich glaube
also das buch von herrn förster ist
natürlich faszinierend und dieses
projekt eben wie die tiere zu lieben wie
wir ein dachs und wer das gemacht hat
ich halte es da glaube ich dann doch
sehr mit dem amerikanischen philosophen
thomas niggl
der in seinem berühmten aufsatz what is
it like to mirbeth also wie ist das eine
fledermaus zu sein eben auf ein dilemma
hingewiesen hat was auch gerade in dem
gespräch kurz anklang nämlich wir können
uns so verhalten wie eine fledermaus
also wir können uns jeden abend zum
schlafen irgendwie mit den beinen nach
oben ins gebälk unseres hauses hängen
wir können fliegen essen
aber wir werden dadurch niemals wissen
wie es ist eine fledermaus zu sein wir
werden immer nur wissen wie es ist als
mensch sich wie eine fledermaus zu
verhalten und ich glaube dieses dilemma
dass man eben in den kopf der fledermaus
oder auch jetzt der amsel nicht
hineinkommt in dem man sich so verhält
wie sie ich glaube das bleibt bestehen
gleichzeitig könnte man schon sagen weil
man eben auch da wieder eine grenze
sozusagen überwinden
eigentlich ein widerstand ist nicht ein
geringer widerstand dass sich so ein
training ist zu merken die fledermaus
bleibt immer anders lernt man vielleicht
auch zu merken auch dass gegenüber
bleibt ein stück weit immer an das ist
eine dauernde arbeit sich einzufühlen
und gleichzeitig die differenz zu
akzeptieren
ja das ist sicherlich richtig ich weiß
dass nichts mit der amsel die ihm
benannt wurde durch die man an bessere
liebhaber der familienvater wird ob das
stimmt dass ich sehr gut über die amsel
auch länger nachgedacht und ich glaube
was man vielleicht wirklich von ihr
sprechen lernen könnte wäre wie man ein
besserer schriftsteller wird weil er die
amsel im gegensatz zu uns menschen wir
sind immer darum bemüht ja relativ
verein deutlichen zu sprechen immer
genau das auszudrücken was wir
vielleicht meinen und die angst die
hatte einen sehr der philosoph michael
wäre würde sagen ein pulli siemen gesang
also ein viel bedeutenden gesang die
sitze auf ihrer fahne oben und sie
zwitschert diese herrliche melodien die
wie beethoven klingen aber sagt sie
damit das hier ist mein revier oder sagt
sie kommen hier zum jedem schönes amsel
weibchen oder sagt sie was war ein
herrlicher tag die sonne geht endlich
auf oder sagt sie hier oben ist sie aus
ich toll auf dieser blautanne oder sagt
sie dass alles auf einmal also ich
glaube sie hat einen sehr sehr viele
deutungen gesang und das ist wiederum
etwas das vielleicht für dichter und
schriftsteller und komponisten natürlich
sehr
vorbildhaft sein könnte ich weiß nicht
ob familienvater und liebhaber
sie schreiben das merkt man wenn man
ihnen zuhört über ganz viele tiere sie
haben lange zeit auch eine kolumne
geschrieben über verschiedene tiere
trottel war ein tier ohrenquallen
fledermaus zwei wochen also die liste
ist endlos
ich möchte ein tier mit regen noch
heraus greifen nämlich die schnecke weil
sie da auch ein wunderbares büchern
geschrieben haben und weil die schnecke
sie natürlich auf den weg des geringsten
widerstandes immer wieder begleitet und
ich habe tatsächlich zwei schnecken
mitgebracht noch zusätzlich weil ich das
auch interessiert warum sie die schnecke
so interessant finden wir nehmen mal ein
tierchen vielleicht raus darf ich das
jetzt ich bin nicht so schnell so viel
geschrieben
richtig es ist uns wichtig dass so jetzt
kann sie mir mal erzählen was ist
eigentlich an diesem tier philosophisch
interessant weiß nicht offensichtlich
sehr wohl hier wie sie das gemacht habe
mit dem seebad unzählige ist aber ich
glaube das offensichtlichste ist erstmal
das ist ja fast ein ja nicht zufrieden
ist aber ein extrem ambivalentes tier
also dass einerseits diese herrliche
mathematischer genauigkeit und präzision
des gehäuses also mit dieser
logarithmischen spirale die also auch
zum beispiel große architekten
beeinflusst hat corbusier zum beispiel
der große schweizer architekt hat immer
schneckenhäuser gesammelt und skizzen
angefertigt sogar glaubt sein erstes
strandhaus entworfen nach dem vorbild
eines schneckenhauses also ihnen
wirklich ein architektonisches
wunderwerk dieses gehäuse und dann aber
dieser körper der dahinter steckt dass
sie diese kontrast von form und inhalt
der wirklich faszinierend also diese
jedoch sehr amor für körper der eben
diese unglaubliche strategie entwickelt
hat so cents auf der erde zu schwimmen
also eben durch eine schleuse sein
eigenes wasserbett zu produzieren und
darauf an er zu gleiten
das sind schon mal zwei sachen die du
hast mir finde was ich auch unglaublich
faszinierend finde ich das eben die
frage aufwerfen in diesem schnecken buch
ob die schnecke eigentlich auch ihr haus
ist also wenn die schnecke ins haus
zurück geht wie dieses exemplar hier der
ist ja hier verkaufen geht sie dann ins
haus oder geht sie in sich genau wie
denkt ja immer so von dem schneckenhaus
ihm als am gehäuse das irgendwie separat
wäre von der schnecke aber das ist
natürlich nicht der fall sein wenn es
ist ein teil ihres körpers sie kann er
nicht der ein- und ausgehen dass machen
vielleicht später die einzige die krebse
wenn die strecke gestorben ist aber sie
man muss nicht vorstellen dass sie fast
das gehäuse aus sich heraus schwitzt aus
ihren rücken also das ist der
kalkablagerungen dieser bildet auf ihrem
rücken und die sie eben aus ihrem körper
produziert das heißt was uns wie ein
haus erscheint es doch ein integraler
bestandteil von ihr selbst geht ihm sich
wenn sie ins haus geht in sich
verkrümmt sich gewissermaßen in sich und
ist dann doch ganz bei sich und
verschließt er auch gerne dann ihr
gehäuse mit einem mit einem deckel also
ein kalk deckel bei den weinberg stecken
und verbringt den ganzen winter ich
glaube das herz schlägt nur so ein mal
pro minute oder zweimal ist das denn sie
kann das prinzipiell jahre lang machen
und da wo sich im denken
louis ist es ja ein bisschen
außergewöhnlich sich so intensiv mit
schnecken zu befassen die frist
tatsächlich seien aber ich habe sie eine
salat fressende schnecke gesehen wie
kommen sie darauf ausgerechnet über
schnecken ein buch zu schreiben
vielleicht ist ein ähnlicher impuls
gewesen wie das wanderbuch zu schreiben
also ist wo sie fragen fällt mir auf
dass ist doch ähnlich ist weil der der
gea und die schnecke haben sehr viel
glaube ich miteinander gemein als sie
weiß eigentlich sehr und modernes machen
eben sie bewegen sich sehr entschleunigt
voran was eben auch in dem ausland über
ludwigsburger schon einklang leben dass
man bewusst sich gegen die
beschleunigung der welt richtet das ist
ja heute noch viel viel virulenter es in
den 70er 80er jahren der große soziologe
hartmut rosa der mehrere bücher
geschrieben zur beschleunigung des
gesellschaft und zur resonanz auch genau
und eben aber auch zur entschleunigung
beschleunigung wo er eben zeigt dass
sozusagen das reisetempo hat sich seit
dem 19 jahrhundert jung dass ich glaube
180 fache gesteigert des kommunikations
tempo um das hunderttausendfach hase mit
dem echten whatsapp nachrichten die man
schickt im vergleich zum brief und dann
ist eben das gen ist ja etwas sehr
radikal anti modernes wenn man so will
und genau so ist eben auch die die
schnecke etwas angst ein urtümliches
tier die eben sehr sehr langsam ihr ding
macht und damit aber gleichzeitig doch
evolutionär unglaublich erfolgreich ist
also man muss sich klarmachen schnecken
gibt es in dieser form seit über einen
einer halben milliarde jahren sei es
sind dreimal so alt wie die alpen das
heißt es kann nicht alles falsch sein
was sie machen also sie machen das sehr
langsam aber sehr effizient was sie tun
weiß man etwas darüber hätte schnecken
jeweils den weg des geringsten
widerstands gehen wenn die einem
hindernis ausweichen oder gehen die
einfach gemütlich gerade auf sie könnten
ja wie man weiß auch über eine
messerklinge kriechen wenn sie müssten
ich habe auf meiner wanderung immer
wieder auch die spuren der schnecken
beobachtet natürlich also an einem
morgen nachdem es im gefecht war in
einer flussaue oder so sieht man ja sehr
schön immer diesen spuren und da hat das
gefühl einerseits das ist schon sehr
sehr zufällig wie die sich bewegen also
es ist auf keinen fall die direkte linie
sondern es ist wahrscheinlich der weg
des geringsten widerstandes
und ich habe mich selber natürlich dann
doch sehr in der schnecke gespiegelt
sehen und dachte wenn er es eben
irgendjemand mich von oben beobachtet
egal wer das ist ob gott oder google
earth
dann sieht das wahrscheinlich ganz
ähnlich aus wie die spuren die diese
schnecke hinterlässt auf der erde ich
gehe auch so in diesen merkwürdigen
schleimigen geschnitten spuren aus der
schnecke natürlich philosophisch gesehen
auch interessant macht und was sie auch
lange diskutieren ist das
geschlechterverhältnis könnte man mal
sagen unter unter den schnecken
also das sind ja eigentlich zwitter und
die können mal männchen mal weibchen
sein die könnte ich sogar auch selber
befruchten genau es gibt einige arten
die sogar bevorzugen sich selber zu
befruchten auch wenn partner in der nähe
wären es gibt welche die sind werden als
menschen geboren ist dann später
weibchen und dann im alter wieder
menschen und eben welche wie die
weinbergschnecke die sind tatsächlich
lebenslange twitter können also beide
parteien nehmen und das hinterfragt
natürlich wirklich ganz dramatisch
unsere annahme neben von
geschlechterparität das war es gibt eben
männer und frauen und ja und vielleicht
noch ein drittes geschlecht das wird
natürlich seit einigen jahren vermehrt
diskutiert oder auch menschen die wir
wieder noch sind
aber die flecken machen dass das eben
auch wiederum seit einer halben
milliarden jahre vor dass es auch ganz
anders geht und dass man eben nicht in
diesen binären strukturen immer denken
muss immer sie immer wieder verlassen
kann
insofern könnte man sagen die sind also
wirklich fleischgewordene hetero
normativität kritik die tierchen und für
sie auch ein vorbild in diesem hinblick
nicht unbedingt aber sozusagen dieses
unbeschwerte scheinbar unbeschwerte ganz
bei sich runde leben das sie uns
vormachen dass das wenn ich schon mal
wieder faszinierend man merkt aber auch
die ihre faszination für die schnecke
hab irgendwie auch etwas zu tun und
jetzt mal ein platz zu sagen mit dem
weiblichen geschlecht ja oder geht es
sehr sehr lange und das schneckenhaus
immer wieder
es geht aber auch um das männliche
geschlecht sie sagen eigentlich ist der
der körper der schnecke ist sozusagen
das männliche geschlecht das schmeckt
genauso und genau man hat eigentlich das
beides in sich vereint also der körper
hat etwas sehr falsch ist wenn man so
möchte und das schneckengehäuse ist
schon auch wiederum seit der antike
eigentlich immer wieder ein symbol für
das weibliche geschlecht gewesen und
wird es auch in der kunstgeschichte
immer wieder gezeigt oder auch in der
auch in der populären kultur ich weiß
nicht ob sie sich noch erinnern
gute szene ursula und ja doch und sie
ist das angeblich muschel taucherin was
ihnen hält das ist natürlich keine
muschel sondern eine schnecke und die
symbolischen dank nicht genau das muss
ich nach kurzen küssel biologisch
gesehen die muschel hat immer zwei
schalen die strecke nur eine aufhören
aufwendigen von meeresschnecken genau
das ist eine meeresschnecke eine ganz
gewaltige und natürlich so wie sie sie
hält und dann ist ja auch noch so rosa
rot gefärbt ist glaube ich die symbolik
völlig klar dass in der nächsten szene
kommt natürlich schon connery als james
bond an und
es dauert nicht mehr lange bis sie eben
zum symbol gemacht wird das heißt dame
mit schneckenhaus ist eine eindeutige
message
das ist ganz eindeutige message auf
jeden fall also auch auf einer aktuellen
rock platte der band the killers genau
ist gerade im frühjahr glaube ich
erschienen habe ich auch gesehen das
wird auch mit genau dieser art von einem
pächter schnecke ist es glaube ich
beworben die genauso in die kamera
gehalten wird und es ist völlig klar es
geht ja nicht um schnecken auf diesem
album es geht um rockende männer und um
die frauen die deswegen vielleicht zu
füßen liegen sehen wir noch mal zur
schnecke zurückgehen glauben sie denn
eine schnecke denkt etwas ist
irgendetwas davon was die tun jetzt
fließt die da ganz gemütlich vor sich
hin
absichtsvoll zum beispiel auf jeden fall
aber es gibt dazu auch untersuchungen
tatsächlich eine sehr rege neuronale
tätigkeit aber ich glaube weit über die
hälfte ihrer nervenbahnen sind damit zu
befestigt damit beschäftigt über das
fressen nachzudenken
das heißt die sind da schon also im
moment glaube ich auch dass diese
schnecke die ist ganz bei diesem jahr
salatblatt und denkt nicht allzu viel
über aristoteles oder philosophische
fragen nach was vielleicht schauen fast
wieder auch dem ziel nahe kenne was sie
gesucht haben als silos gewandert sind
einmal strecke sein
langsam laufen und sich ganz in leeren
es ist vielleicht auch so einen ein
kleines tierchen so dass bei sich und
bei dieser tätigkeit ist diese gerade
vollzieht er mir jetzt zurückkommen
sozusagen auf unserem denkt weg diese
metapher auch überall wenn man mal
überdenken und gehen nachdenkt oder man
geht schrittweise vor zum beispiel oder
über man vollzieht im denkt weg wenn wir
jetzt mal diesen weg noch gehen was
genau ist ihnen am meisten geblieben
jetzt habe irgendetwas von diesem weg
des geringsten widerstandes jetzt etwas
verändert für sie oder eine idee die
sich und der sie denken das ist mir echt
dadurch nochmal so richtig aufgegangen
eine sache an die ich immer wieder denke
ist natürlich
trifft man unterwegs wenn man nach dem
prinzip das grinsen widerstandes läuft
entscheidungen wo man sich drei tage
später frage ob die eigentlich richtig
waren also dann weht im wind münchen von
westen und man gehe nach osten und
landet dann aber irgendwo wo es
eigentlich es nicht besonders schönes
und ich glaube was ich sozusagen für
mein leben daraus heraus gezogen habe
war so eine gewisse demut gegenüber
solchen entscheidungen dass man eben
sagt klar man hat diese momente der ruhe
in seinem leben weil man auf seinem
lebensweg bestimmte entscheidung
getroffen hat aber sich zu sagen es gab
offensichtlich damals ein grund warum
man diesen weg beschritten hat genau der
der wind der werte eben von westen oder
die sonne die china ebenso angenehm ins
gesicht dass ich ihr entgegen laufen
musste und deswegen bin ich jetzt an dem
punkt wo ich mich befinde und jetzt
beschreitet den weg weiter so gut es
eben geht ohne zurück zu gehen ohne im
groll im zorn zurück zu blicken auf eine
entscheidung die man getroffen hat auf
diesem weg vielleicht könnte man sowas
sagen wie aktiv herum ihren ist
unglaublich wieder ständig das ist
schwierig das haben sie auch ihr
rhythmus gefunden aber von oben
betrachtet ist das leben manchmal ein
eis oder ein herumirren und in dieser
sichtweise kann man auch persönlich sein
mit sich auf jeden fall also wir merken
auch so viel wir planen genau den ort zu
bestimmen wo wir hin gelangen werden
dass das können wir alle nicht
es gibt ja dieses schöne sprichwort wer
besser plant liegt genau daneben
und ich glaube wenn man sich und sei es
auch nur versuchsweise einmal diesem
prinzip des geringsten widerstandes
anvertraut dann kann man eben diese
einsicht machen ich weiß nicht ob es
wirklich für das ganze leben ein guter
leitfaden ist immer alle widerstände aus
dem weg zu gehen
ich denke zum beispiel an die
kindererziehung da ist es vermutlich
nicht opportun wenn man jeden widerstand
was wäre aber ist zumindest als einen
gegenkurs betrachten die idee zu dieser
ständigen vertikalen spannung in der wir
uns befinden
das fand ich sehr bereichernd wir sind
am ende unseres gesprächs ich danke
ihnen sehr kirkegaard sagte mal bleibt
man angehen so geht es schon
ich glaube so ist es ich danke ihnen
dass sie
wir waren ich danke ihm ja nächste woche
unterhält sich wolfram eilenberger mit
eva von rebecca über das neu erwachte
interesse an der philosophie von hannah
arendt weiter geht's jetzt mit selena
franze und ihrer unglaublich
erfolgreichen jahre sagen eine geniale
freundinnen der film nimmt die spur der
autorin aus und lässt schriftsteller
kollegen zu wort kommen viel vergnügen
mit dem film und bis bald
[Musik]